[Music]
in prepare your heart news Oh submitted
by dude sada oh I feel like there's
gonna be fine
a six-year-old boy was hospitalized
after standing up to his friends bullies
oh hold on was hospitalized I never like
loved this story so like that's you love
are like what he did yeah like that the
reason for it because this says
hospitalized how bad is it he got [ __ ]
up from the bullies what the [ __ ] man
alright you can't just put it on silent
there go the Wi-Fi still on good no
Wi-Fi okay that's why still hold up I
wasn't ready she wasn't ready
bullies know his friends believable dude
any six an honor more honorable dude yet
I like it oh man yeah so this kid his
name is Carter six years old from
Washington Kaabah he is yeah so they're
saying that he is on the autism spectrum
who pave and he stood up to the six
bullies seven possibly seven they're
saying maybe cuz wait younger or older
cuz this could be like about the same
age but they [ __ ] him up what the [ __ ]
are these six-year-olds do oh oh so he
initially saw that his friend is being
picked on so he was like he stood up
because they hate stop picking on him
and then all of a sudden he flips in and
did it too
oh so maybe we'll pick on you then we're
throwing rocks sticks and they rubbed
sawdust into it this will be Amazon what
is this
where's this Washington sawdust like you
guys smell that's hanging out like on
the floor like riding aboard I don't
know it's an apartment building complex
he they did all this to him so his mom
she went home for lunch she's a single
mom of four dams three jobs to support
her kid chilidogs
yeah it's like when she went to
when she went home on her lunch break
she saw Mike he was sitting out there
like on the front of the house and he
was just like [ __ ] up so then she go
inside the house maybe he knew hello
respect cuz yeah so much solidus on his
body or something but who thinks about
rubbing sawdust in somebody's eye that's
some [ __ ] vindictive [ __ ] sounds like
they didn't even realize what it was
they just saw it and then it means like
these kids are getting abused themselves
dude what are they learning this wrong
[ __ ] those kids dude yeah so he was
saying that he didn't know the name of
the other kids but he did know one
little like the name of one of them so
he was five years old
the police found with the six-year-old
got beat up by a five-year-old survival
rate was in that group borderline
toddler yeah my first ass beating when I
was six years old and the guy was six
years old and when I got my I got picked
on mouth and I never experienced
violence from another person besides my
parents and he just kept kicking and
kicking and kicking I just started
crying I had a bloody ass mouth and I
was just crying to know what to do so I
just ran home when I was in kindergarten
we were playing house and somebody tried
to take my pot when I was cooking in the
house as I think that pot I smacked him
in the face my whole life you know it
was just his little girl she's just a
[ __ ] she pulled my hair she yeah and
then I got her neck violent though I got
my ass beat I was five he was like both
his name father he's watching her and I
was like I thought we solved this no
this is not what he say he's like shut
the [ __ ] is your phone going off fathers
angry kids are vicious yeah so he knows
Carter
what is he Chinese or Mexican he's so
damn cute oh it's not my Nunez dude did
they take pictures when you asleep well
that was the first one
oh man we had to have eye surgery and
the doctor said that he could have lost
his eye and his eyesight that's what
doctors always say though he got that
Tijuana blanket though yeah
that's it's comfortable as hell it's got
to have a bear on it like a bear attack
or a bear Rose is something so 35 would
be like the combined age of all know
what I would have done the same [ __ ] he
would have done but I would have
protected that kid from a distance dude
because he actually confronted them
he should have assessed the situation
there's seven kids you know though he
was the IV's [ __ ] I don't think any of
them know I feel like they're all like
super young yeah Hugh this is quote they
were just bullying him and beating him
up
I told I just told them to stop and then
they did it to me I'm brave dope I would
have done from distance like behind the
fence hey pick on somebody all sides
real quick you guys are bullies real
fast dude Jack's on the forty trip on it
but that appeal barbels everything
what's wrong that we're fat kid just
asian wasn't home alone yeah I'll have a
pigeon lady beat the buck to get away
from me boys fractured his elbow and
three places one and he has a broken arm
the body slam listen I don't know but
they're saying that he might kiss girl
oh she should go to jail
he might possibly have to have surgery
on his elbow that their dad is so bad
that is their juvie for six there should
be they found that five-year-old right
but that they're not obviously they're
not gonna take him to jail or anything
why
[Laughter]
they're gonna get social services
involved so they're gonna find out like
what kind of home they're living in for
them to do digits they could even just
be in a good-ass home but just kids are
just [ __ ] nuts
yeah those crazy is that like it gets
into that like at what age do you charge
someone for real [ __ ] I was wanting no I
think you're close it's something like
that because then there's like a
psychological change that happens that
now they're aware that they're doing
something for the sake of harming isn't
that subjective though cuz your kid can
just be really slow so like if they're
13 but they're I guess they're like
their class age is like kindergarten
about those kids I hear like in the
movies obviously cuz I don't think I've
heard of this in real life but when they
there's like 7 8 year olds that are
killing other people like do they go to
jail by some City of God you mean yes
that's what I was thinking that's a
great man I think that's when they have
this us like that person situation ok
good what would you do if you found that
that tiger was one of the kids that beat
up the autistic child oh I'll beat the
[ __ ] out attack another autistic child
not beating the [ __ ] out of them I'm
just gonna let the autistic child beat
his ass know what if that guy wins again
how does it come back was almost 1 years
old right it's gonna be one he's the
size of a 14 year old huge dude that's a
girl at the age of 5 death was gonna
kick my ass I'm just saying that you
have to be careful like putting him back
into a cage with that kid again his ID
he'll just [ __ ] him up on the feel like
he wasn't fighting back
I don't like he was the sweet kid yeah
he was did he leave him alone are you to
fight no you two deserve this yeah come
on kid you should have read dude you
didn't know do marbles Jax banana peels
that was like me I got kicked in the
mouth I could I ran but I'd even it was
just so shocking that I just did that
his hip getting [ __ ] boom boom oh
I've seen boom now look with him from
this
never stops training because he's like
never again no never again
dad yeah every time I saw a bullet up
like in elementary school the kids that
didn't fight back they got more like
more and more [ __ ] up yeah like like
they'll ball up and then don't go in a
corner and they'll just like hide or
whatever they just kept getting kicked
or something but then the kids that
would like bite and scratch and go crazy
everyone was like don't [ __ ] with that
kid man and don't follow me in the mouth
that [ __ ] yes yeah
would you really get like bullied
physically or mentally physically a
hundred percent I've been yeah bullied
physically and I think I got over that
but mentally is this hard hard [ __ ]
that's these girls do that mental mind
dude girls are so little girls are so
[ __ ] up dude they're like gang up on
them they exclude them out of the group
make them feel like they're worthless
I mean actually tend to be friends to
get dirt on that yeah I see a nagy man
it's physical if you're not dead then
you're good but psychologically you mind
crazy reasons like I was like why you so
mean to her because she's because she
caused all the boys like her
yeah but what the balls on IG or higher
like why cuz she's prettier like that's
crazy
no she's writes good catch are you the
new girl in school you want to be our
friend cool boom next day spreads a
rumor about that girl [ __ ] special
life is done yeah I've done for the rest
of your life girls it was for a reason
oh yeah it makes sense yeah girls don't
trust girls
damn cuz guys are just like up fried if
they don't like you for the most guys
are just as bad some guys are just as
bad some guys right but for the most
part I think if they don't like you it's
hard for them to be so conniving yeah
young kids young kids and you know as
you're older you get yeah cuz they're
just like I hate you why cuz you wear
glasses like okay that's that's kind of
like little boys [ __ ] dude I'm so
[ __ ] like honest sometimes like dude
when I first came to LA I had to learn
how to be smart about how you speak to
people in who you know cuz you can't
just like these important people who can
like basically push your career forward
if you don't like then you can't show it
on your face but I couldn't get rid of
my face so I would say nice things but
my face wouldn't you
example time how you doing it would be
like doing your [ __ ] face you're
still angry in your face but your voice
sounds nice at least your tone didn't or
volume didn't change that I'm like I
love you okay you're freaking awesome
yeah
I like your [ __ ] shoes [ __ ] when I
went up when I went to mix TV with her
right I know who I was talking to but I
think it was a guy named Anthony but he
was like are you angry at me and I was
like no I'm not angry he goes why is
your face so angry I'm just listening so
I don't know how to like undo my face a
little bit yeah I'm just like you gotta
resting [ __ ] try to learn how to
just you know hey how's it going how's
it going I just didn't I didn't know
that I would just sprout all the time
have you guys ever bullied without
knowing that you're probably like
someone's really sensitive though I
don't think I've ever bullied but I
tough loved a lot of people that's bully
is that boiling yeah I don't know
there's a no boy is intentionally trying
to like do a dark side but that is like
trying to bring the positive out of that
but then I'm like like when you're
[ __ ] with someone because like let's
say let's say it's funny to watch
someone be scared
right and you're pranking them and then
you go overboard and then you like watch
them suffer and you think that's really
funny like as a kid a lot of people do
that and that's bullying even though
it's not like the bullying where you're
intimidating and hurting them and taking
their money it's kind of like you're
using people as entertainment that's the
kind of bully doubt that I did and I and
I [ __ ] up but it's like when I'm
laughing I can't stop like it's
something takes all over me you know
that's so funny and you just keeps
laughing at them I think as a bullying
situation - not that I agree with it at
all but you also have to let that
nonsense if they accept it for to be for
someone to bully you
does that make sense because we here
hate comments all the time yeah and
we're like you're right we just gave
them touting what's that you saying that
bullying only happens if you let the
bully happen yeah but at that age it's
kind of tough to know whether like you
don't know that yet so that's why I
understand it's like it's a different
place yeah cuz now someone tries to
bully you it's way harder to do it
because
like if they say some crazy words
they're just like okay but then when
you're a kid and someone's like oh
you're so stupid cuz your hats ugly
nobody called you bartenders I didn't
know I had a choice and feelings back
then
ah that is yeah I just hurt my feelings
that's actually Barse that's yeah that's
true I'm sure every kid doesn't yeah but
now it's like some of them like you're
dumb
[Music]
[Music]